[Music]
we have good news pastor Andrew Brunson
is in the air from Turkey he's going to
be coming to the Oval Office most likely
on Saturday the he suffered greatly but
we're very appreciative to a lot of
people a lot of people there was no deal
made at all been a roller coaster ride
we've been finding our news out just
like everyone else has right now we're
overjoyed but it still doesn't quite
seem real great news
pastor Bronson released from Turkey on
his way to the US it's been a long time
two years five days ago he was detained
by Turkish police without charges two
months later he was charged with
membership in an armed terrorist
organization for allegedly backing a
coup attempt in Turkey face 35 years in
prison July he was taken from prison
placed under house arrest and in August
the u.s. puts some sanctions on a couple
of Turkish officials today again he is
leaving time served already the sentence
releasing a statement we are grateful
for the president's commitment and
efforts in securing my release my entire
family thanks to president the
administration and Congress for their
unwavering support this is the day our
family has been praying for I'm
delighted to be on my way home to the
United States a finally a good news
story on a Friday of a busy week let's
bring in our panel and start there
matthew cottan Ettie editor-in-chief of
the washington free beacon Karen Tumulty
opinion writer for The Washington Post
and Mark teason fellow at the American
Enterprise Institute mark good news
story and sounds like the president
making clear no deal was done absolutely
in this how he had this is how he does
it it is a big news story this is the
17th American by my count that President
Trump has freed from foreign captivity
there was a four Americans in North
Korea American aid worker in Egypt three
UCLA basketball players and a and a
Texas businesswoman in China see a
former CIA official and Portugal
American citizen held in Venezuela he's
been doing this fairly consistency it
made it a priority of his foreign policy
and
done it not by giving bribes not by
sending plane loads of cash with
unmarked bills to two foreign regimes
because that creates an incentive to
take Americans hostage she's done it by
exercising the coercive economic and
diplomatic power of the United States of
America he people at crushing sanctions
on Turkey that sent the lira tumbling
and Turkey wanted out and they finally
found an opportunity to do it Karen yeah
it's it and they had also made it for
the administration had also made it
pretty clear that this was necessary for
improving relations the timing is
interesting given that Turkey has also
been turning over a lot of intelligence
on the possible apparent murder of our
colleague Jamal khashoggi our colleague
at the Washington Post
so Turkey could be playing sort of a
double game here to sort of position
itself in its rivalry with Saudi Arabia
yeah there are real economic costs to
the captivity of Reverend Brunson
there's no question and as Mark said
this Trump's method is to leverage the
economic weight of the United States
against regimes that are doing no good
so this is a victory not only for the
administration but also a victory for
religious freedom because we can't
forget why he was imprisoned in the
first place and that was his ministry
and so I think a lot of Christians
around the world will appreciate that
he's now been released Karen you
mentioned the missing journalists
khashoggi the president talking about
that today on the tarmac as well we're
gonna find out what happened with
respect to the terrible situation in
Turkey having to do with Saudi Arabia
and the reporter I think a lot of
Records are overlooked if you look at
Iran if you look at so many other
countries take a look at Syria you take
a look at a lot of countries a lot of
countries records have been overlooked I
will be calling at some point King
Salman so where does this go you know
there's reporting in multiple news
organizations saying that there's US
intelligence showing that there are
intercepts or calls or recordings the
Turkish say that they have heard and
seen evidence of this although we have
not been privy to that as far as we know
is that correct that's right and
the other thing though that we have
gotten from US intelligence The
Washington Post reported however was
that the crown prince had in fact okayed
an earlier plan to to lure Jamal
Khashoggi to Saudi Arabia and
essentially abduct him there so there
are a lot of signs a lot of arrows
pointing to the very top top levels of
the Saudi government okay this let's
just stipulate this is heinous if it
happened and if they find out it
happened it's it's horrific from people
who look at regimes and how they deal
with things around the world is there
any daylight in dealing with a regime
that it turns out did this it's very
hard because this is I mean this is at
both criminal and it's a betrayal a
personal betrayal of President Donald
Trump President Trump has embraced MBSA
the the Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
it was his first country that he visited
as president of United States
he made deals with them he's shifted our
foreign policy in the Middle East away
from courting Iran and trying to bring
them around and towards supporting our
allies like Saudi Arabian Israel and so
he put a lot of on the line MBS if he's
behind this betrayed President Trump and
the United States
Matthieu which is why it would help to
have evidence that the crown prince was
behind it we don't really have evidence
yet even the plot that Karen described
is far different from what the Turks are
accusing the Saudis of doing which is
torturing murdering and then
dismembering him in the consulate in
Istanbul not in Saudi Arabia I think
there's a lot of people on Capitol Hill
who are still looking for answers and
evidence as well as in the
administration we also have to remember
that this Saudi u.s. alliance carries
great costs and has carried great costs
for decades but if that were alliance
were to break there'd be costs as well
and so as we evaluate the punishment
that should be meted out if the crime
should be proven we have to keep in mind
that what the Middle East doesn't need
is another failed
date Karin less work well I do think
though that it is incumbent on us to on
the United States to do what we can to
get a clear answer the Saudis are saying
he left he left the consulate if that is
the case there should be evidence of
that we'll follow it it's an amazing
story